until recently Brett Weinstein was a
biology professor to Evergreen State
College in Oregon last year though a
campus mom targeted him when he refused
to leave campus because of the color of
his skin
you took a principled position as a
liberal by the way Weinstein later felt
he had to resign he did this week he
testified to Congress about free speech
on campus and after he did that he spoke
with us there it is professor thanks for
joining us
I took air thanks for inviting me back
on so well amazingly it's been a year
since all of this happened and we talked
to you right in the middle of it you've
had a lot of time to reflect on it what
are the lessons that you're taking from
the experience that you went through wow
it is hard to imagine that it's been a
year but it has been almost exactly a
year and much has changed I think one of
the things that's most important is that
the conversation is in a very different
place than it was last May we are now
able to discuss issues of identity
politics and though people are still
inflamed on both sides of that dialogue
we are able to have those discussions in
a way that was virtually impossible last
May it seems to me that there is
actually a recognition that the country
is in danger and it's being placed in
danger by identity politics both on the
far right and the far left and so I see
a movement led in part by the
intellectual dark web and the heterodox
Academy and fire towards what I would
call the patriotic center where people
who disagree over many issues of policy
find themselves aligned over basic
American principles yes so as I recall
you mean you were kind of caught unaware
by this you were absorbed in your
academic discipline you were kind of a
traditional free speech liberal you
didn't fully appreciate what had been
happening on campus until you stood up
and took the traditionally liberal
position that you shouldn't attack
people on the basis of their skin color
and you got pounded off campus and
threatened with violence
how have you reconciled to the Evergreen
itself have you spoken to the president
of the college that they apologized to
you where does that all stand now
while they have done quite the opposite
of apologizing they have in fact hired a
PR team that periodically demonizes my
wife and myself in the Olympian the
local paper and the paper of the state
capital and things on campus have
actually grown as much as it's hard to
imagine much worse than they were during
the riots of May 2017 so the Evergreen
State College has taken a turn towards
the authoritarian that is nothing if not
breathtaking people are being fired for
their willingness to offer any sort of
challenge to the administration those
who support the administration in its
reckless quest for what is falsely
called equity are being promoted and the
college faces a terrible financial
crisis as a result of the fact that
students are not showing up having seen
what the campus is descending into
people have decided to go elsewhere for
college which has put the college six
million dollars in the red it's also sad
and crazy so unless I'm missing
something all you did was say I'm not
gonna leave because I'm the wrong skin
color I mean took a kind of traditional
civil rights position I think on what
was going on at Evergreen on what
grounds are they attacking you what are
they saying about you well ironically
the challenge the one that appears to
resonate with people on the far left is
that my talking to you during the riots
brought violence from the alt-right to
campus which is I stretch to say at
least it's not that there weren't
threats to the campus there were there
was one threat in particular phoned in
from a man in New Jersey who claimed to
have a gun and be heading for campus he
did not have a gun and at any rate was
in New Jersey but but the the argument
effectively is that standing up and
speaking about what was taking place was
breaking ranks in a way that damaged the
college but what has never said is that
you invited me to talk to you and your
audience at a time
and the rest of the press was looking
the other way and what is hard for
people to appreciate is that at the time
that I was on your program the president
of the college George bridges had
literally stood down the police force so
that they were unable to intervene
between rioters and members of the
community like myself and the the
rioters took up carrying baseball bats
and batons they challenged people who
disagreed with them physically and so it
was quite a dangerous situation and the
idea that at a moment when as as I
understand it from the chief of police I
was apparently being hunted for car to
car by protesters I don't know what they
had in mind but at a time when that was
taking place in my own neighborhood
going on a program with an audience
understood to be right-of-center was
like some kind of sin ice unbelievable I
thought then and I think now I doubt
we've ever voted for the same candidate
but I really admired your bravery and I
admire it now Thank You professor and
Godspeed
we support you thank you